se refieren a ellos mismos como estado
islámico de jorasán y xisca en honor al
nombre histórico de la región que
incluye partes de pakistán irán
afganistán y asia central
meses después de que declararan un
califato en irak y siria en 2014
luchadores desencantados de los
talibanes de pakistán y de militantes
afganos crearon la versión regional de
este grupo terrorista
el estado islámico se estableció en
afganistán contando con los que estaban
decepcionados con el talibán algunos
comandantes militares muy conocidos
prometieron fidelidad al estado islámico
fueron formalmente reconocidos por los
líderes centrales después de
establecerse en las provincias de kunar
la envergadura y stan en el noreste de
afganistán son enemigos declarados de
los talibanes ya que consideran que su
visión del islam no es suficientemente
dura
expertos en seguridad estiman que su
número de combatientes puede ir desde
los 500 hasta los 2.000 los ejércitos
europeos y de eeuu creen que los
integrantes del issys que operan gracias
a células secretas basadas en las
ciudades han logrado llevar a cabo
varios ataques de alto perfil en el país
de ataque en kabul ya han realizado
varios ataques en kabul muchos mortales
usando carros bomba explosivos caseros y
hasta bombardeos con cohetes de líder
como el último ataque contra el palacio
presidencial antes de la victoria del
grupo talibán fue el estado islámico
quién lo hizo
[Música]
en noviembre pasado atacaron la
universidad de kabul también se cree que
son responsables de un atentado contra
un pabellón de maternidad en un barrio
predominantemente chiíta de la capital
habitado por la minoría hazara y en mayo
un carrobomba mató a 80 alumnas a pesar
de no controlar ningún territorio en la
región se sabe que el grupo se mantiene
activo y es peligroso y que busca
ampliar sus filas con yihadistas y con
personas descontentas con el dominio
talibán